de moins 30 à 50 degrés ici dans la
soufflerie les véhicules sont soumis à
des tests extrême des expériences
habituellement fermés au public
mais pour la journée nationale des
jeunes le site valeo de la verrière se
dévoile aux étudiants de l'estaca 21 de
ses parts qui est thermique finalement
et et je me suis sans adresse ans de
venir visiter pour voir un peu comment
ça fonctionne l'entreprise concrètement
en dehors de l'école j'hésite entre
lapierre aéro et la filière auto et donc
c'est pour ça que je me suis inscrit à
cette visite ce qui m'a intéressé ici
c'est le côté expérimental tous à faire
des expériences
imaginez la technologie de demain c'est
l'objectif de ce centre de recherche et
de développement avec cette visite
l'équipementier automobile espère
séduire les futurs ingénieurs tout ce
qui est qui a trait à la thermique du
véhicule
on travaille ici et le périmètre de plus
en plus grand avec tous les véhicules du
futur
et l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir des
véhicules de plus en plus autonomes et
agréable pour les occupants et donc il
ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
nouvelles choses à faire vectrix ont
beaucoup à la hausse de 106 un marché
qui se développe donc c'est intéressant
pour pour l'environnement pour le côté
financier les côtés - développement
mondial et tout parmi ces étudiants deux
ont déjà prévu leur stage chez valeo
dans les sites de saint denis et en
haute savoie
ils rejoindront les quelques 92 mille
employés de l'entreprise